[Music]
and so goes Ron leaving us with Nikki
and Dawn Rond desandis dropped out of
the race just two days before the New
Hampshire primary which is too bad
because Donald Trump had 27 New insults
he was hoping to
try but that's after Ron was polling in
single digits in New Hampshire and lost
in Iowa to Trump by 30 points true he
was about as popular in Iowa as a cold
SAR at a kissing
booth here he is sounding pretty reliev
beli it's over with if there was
anything I could do to produce a
favorable outcome more campaign stops
more interviews I would do it but I
can't ask our supporters to volunteer
their time and donate their resources if
we don't have a clear path to Victory
it's clear to me that a majority of
Republican primary voters want to give
Donald Trump another chance they watch
his presidency get styed by Relentless
resistance and they see Democrats using
lawfare this day to attack him I signed
a pledge to support the Republican
nominee and I will honor that pledge oh
disgusting right he's actually honoring
a pledge and he calls himself a
politician so Trump picks up yet another
endorsement but I wonder if he took the
time to congratulate
Ron I'd like to take time to
congratulate Ronda santis and of course
a really terrific person who have gotten
to know his wife k for having run a
great campaign for president he did he
ran a a really good campaign oh that is
so
Donald but did he though between his
campaign and the super pack supporting
it desanta spent tens of millions and
still got trounced I haven't seen such a
waste of money since Joy bayar had her
lips
done but was it really a waste to me it
was worth it because for the longest
time the argument was to challenge Trump
with the best alternative almost as a
stress test but also to give those who
wanted a viable replacement to Trump to
have one and they got it they got a few
actually but it still wasn't nearly
enough Trump won big and that's despite
him being attacked on all fronts legally
and in the media so there should be no
more why are we settling with Trump if
you actually had the option and you saw
it flounder it's like saying to America
get off your gas guzzler and embrace
this new electric Revolution well the
option was there and they went with the
gas guzzler Maybe in the future we will
consider it but not right now so to
continue with the car metaphor Ron was a
reliable sedan but Republicans want to
Humvee with monster tires and a built-in
propane grill that will drive over
stalled Priuses shooting lasers and
playing God Bless America with a bald
dieago perched on the
hood Viv what do you make what do you I
mean it's a good point you needed to
have you needed to have I mean you can't
you you guys are great candidates I mean
you and and DeSantis you you were the
you were the fresh voice the smartest
guy in the room Dan santis was the best
Governor you know you can't just say oh
we're stuck with Trump Dan santis was an
excellent Governor I'm not going to
knock him I know how hard of a decision
that is to make it was for me not a
decision that I planned to make until we
took about 20 minutes that night and I
decided on the spot that night after
Iowa you you see the way this is going
let's actually do the right thing for
the country and I'm glad Ron made the
right decision as well I think he has an
outstanding future whatever it is he's
going to have an impact on the country
got to know him a certain amount through
the process and I'm confident he cares
about this country and he's GNA have an
impact on our politics going forward you
guys hang out a lot we didn't hang out
much Ron Ron wasn't a you know
I you guys you know I I think bar
hopping we we didn't you know I was down
but uh but I will say that he could be a
good attorney general or something like
that to tell you the truth about Ron but
I will say this is there was one part of
that that I think we should probably
double click on is I think the super
packs have been all bad for American
politics Democrats Republicans it
doesn't matter the amount of money that
you said was wasted I think a lot of
that money was wasted because I think
the voters could have equally had the
choice without putting up those plastic
30 second TV ads on networks across the
board in Iowa New Hampshire it doesn't
matter it's all Fake Plastic it in the
short run movees some numbers I didn't
play that game I put $30 million of my
own harde earned money into the campaign
I wish it didn't have to work that way
either but it's better than the super
pack too you could have given that to me
I would have I would have put it put you
on the show every
night well you know what once in a while
is good I I think it's better for
everybody but I do think that this is
this is an issue the Republicans can own
coming out of this is we should be the
party that says we want to get the
influence of Mega Money out of politics
We're the Party of we the people and I
do think that could be a pivot for our
party going forward
pat pat didn't you like how he said I
want to double click click on something
that's why he's like vi just that's why
I got like 8% I want cat you called me
this morning in tears over this how are
you taking first of all I would never
call you if I was in
tears you'd be the last person I want to
talk to if I was
upset cuz I would be laughing yeah yeah
no how do you take this uh well look a
lot of people are saying what went wrong
here right he was such a good governor
who handled covid so well how did this
go so badly and I think part of it was
that he pretty much like never brought
that up yeah that's all the co stuff and
you know the freedom that Florida had he
was you know instead of talking about
that he was like I'm going to run
against drag queens he got so into the
drag queens are bad and the Disney is
bad that honestly I'm all for the
parents rights stuff that's not what I'm
talking about but he went so far that
some of it was actually anti-p parents
rights like some of the laws were like
you can't bring your child into what is
an adult performance that's determined
by the government I just don't want the
government to tell me where I could
bring my kids if I had them stay tuned
maybe someday okay but um one guy's like
do it um but yeah I think he he wasn't
even really that focused on the right
things so but also I think it was going
to be Trump no matter what what do you
say say Adam you are an astute political
analyst astute uh I don't know I think
the his polls were rough I've seen
better looking polls in a Montana strip
club um and that's in the day shift
um but I it's crazy because people are
gonna vote for Nikki Haley some people
are just cuz she's a woman because we
had our first black president then we
had our first orange president and you
know now we have our first Dead
president
um
[Applause]
but I you I think anyone's better than
now I live in California and like gas is
so expensive people are doing walk by
shootings you know and um like there's
more needles on the ground than a Nancy
Pelosi's forehead
um it's just I don't know why you
dropped out you were doing doing good
thank you I appreciate you should have
stuck in there but uh I don't know I
don't know what's going to happen what
about you Emily you get the last word it
just always strikes me as so it's really
impressive to me when candidates you
know suspend their campaign and then all
of a sudden everyone else is like I'm so
honored to have your endorsement like
everything is fine I guess it's the
Sicilian in me but if someone even looks
at me wrong I'm like I wish you nothing
but death forever so the the like turn
I'm like oh my gosh you guys are such
big hearts um I I think what's really
interesting actually is what might well
probably will happen in New Hampshire so
we know that Trump was ahead of Nikki by
17 points even before Dan santis dropped
out right so the question remains how
many Independents and Democrats will
Haley get but to me the bigger question
is the fact that Biden's not actually on
the ticket and we have someone named
Dean Phillips running who's running
hilarious ads of Sasquatch looking for
the president where is he because he's
nowhere and I think it's it's really
going to be interesting how well he does
because that might be what induces other
sort of big name Democrats to step in
and be like Biden get out of the way so
do you notice that Dean Phillips and D
santis are never in the same room
together oh my gosh it's it's bizarre
it's bizarre and they are dead
ringers put that in post pictures
together no it's Ser I'm serious they
look exactly I noticed that absolutely
yeah it's creepy it's like Sasquatch and
joy bear yes
exactly how dare you impune
Sasquatch all right hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else